hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to when
you hear the word critic what's the very
first thing you think of I know I know
but aside from me what's the first thing
you think of when you hear the word
critic No get him off screen all right
aside from me and the nerd what's the
first thing you think of when you hear
the word Crick
one true part a sign for me the nerd and
half naked violinist running down the
street screwing it's it's gone even and
to be honest
I'll clued you the probably the
best-known movie critics in all of media
they're trustworthy tagline thumbs-up
and thumbs-down is still being used even
today well what is it about them that's
so damn memorable it's ironic that the
lasting impression movies leave on them
creates a lasting impression that these
to leave on us don't try to understand
it sends your brain will explode so what
is it about them that worked that always
kept us watching well let's take a look
and find that this is my official
tribute to my favorite critics of all
time Gene Siskel and Roger E
as a television duo they got their start
in 1975 on PBS
it was our local show called opening
soon at a theater near you which was
later retitled sneak previews okay Ebert
era looks like a hairpiece Siskel hell
he actually has I can match it I have
goofy hair in the past and no hair right
now if the show continued to evolve the
title changed to Cisco and Eva at the
movies and then eventually just Siskel
and Ebert yeah look at that cheesy 80s
opening Jasper ain't in corn ear
actually at the end here when they start
to argue I would always joke about what
I thought that was saying did you kill
the hook no I thought you kill I didn't
kill her I thought you killed your job
to kill her well not with her change our
identities now the idea of putting movie
critics on TV was nothing new if I
cooperate it's a dead before but this
was one of the few times where the
formula was putting to critics together
so they can compare and analyze their
opinions I didn't like this move I
didn't like little Norman Oh most
critics would just go on by themselves
delivering their review much like how
they would write it for an article
this movie is filled with wonders for
every family for kiddies and for daddies
and of course for mummies yeah but
that's my Siskel and Ebert differ they
did just speak they're written for you
or spew out one liars they talked about
it like how most people do what do I
know about Nintendo very little but I
know this I once got to the second level
of Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles and so
in this movie when they talk about hey I
got to the third level and show the
screen even dummy like me I know enough
that they only got to the first level
but not only did they talk about they
talked about in an intelligent way these
were two bright guys who adored movies
and Dority analyzing what's good about
them and bad about them as a whole
speech about McDonald's stores in
Amsterdam that is fun to listen to the
things they talk about is I think
working I think that this guy was
writing some of the most original
dialogue since David Mamet but as you'd
imagine they didn't always agree and
this is where the show really shined the
arguments people love to see these two
go ad he reminded me of a Clark Gable in
the way that he had this role this is
gonna sound you but I'm giving the movie
thumbs so does it stand me are you okay
I think if people go with the right
state of mind they're gonna have a tree
yeah I have a couple of martinis but
they're bickering was only fueled by
their opposite personalities Gene Siskel
seem much more stuck-up and snooty than
Ebert
which usually meant you a nitpick a
movie and measure his pros and cons I
don't like this Joker's voice but it's
the drawing style that really
distinguishes Batman mask of the
phantasm
Roger Ebert on the other hand seemed
much more emotional and personally which
means he would analyze the movie as a
whole more like an experience it's
amusing it moves and somewhat to my
surprise I liked it because of this they
all set each other
perfectly their arguments would get so
heated that people actually wondered if
they really hated each other even on
other shows they would always go for the
low blow Valentine's Day I'm trying to
decide whether to get Roger the 30 bound
box of chocolates or the 60 pound box
you know those ankle rings you can hang
upside down and supposed to you know
bring a lot of blood to the scalp it
might help I don't know so you guys are
getting along pretty well done it is
true that relationship was very hard to
figure out the claim they never hung out
outside of work but the way they acted
sometimes UsWe they were brothers
fighting over a toy try one it's
thriller week on Siskel and Ebert at the
movies and we've got three Noah and the
movie not at the movies that's this week
on Siskel and Ebert and the movie and
the asshole and that's Roger
in fact this video of them shooting a
promo has gotten a ton of hits on
YouTube just for that very reason Roger
is the only guy in the history to ever
answer yes to every question he's asked
at McDonald's but for as many insults
each of them could take they always
douchebag double the amount when they
saw gene Wacha dead with a little little
kid behind the counter call for the
manager and said mr. Jones can you come
out here you can understand mr. Sisco
can't you but at least they could agree
on one thing
they both fucking hate Protestants
goddamn Protestant bigger thing to
happen through them on Sunday is a bake
sale no they got to decide what color
yellow to try to fucking buy that's
right the only fucking religion has The
Reader's Digest as a prayer book I would
just like to point out that up not all
critics are prejudiced against certain
religions I for example am only
prejudice against these especially the
middle one the personalities were so
likable that they've been satirized time
and time again my personal favorites are
the Animaniacs episode if you want to go
on national TV and shred someone's
career to pieces you have the right but
when you do that remember don't go
listing
Oh address in the phone book the home of
hisskill and eggbert unexpectedly
exploded today at this episode of the
crane where Siskel and Ebert actually
supplied their own voices hasta LaVista
porky cue ball in a side pocket the cool
thing about them is that even if you
don't agree with their review they're
still incredibly fun to listen to
like I love how you burped actually
thought Congo was supposed to be bad and
it's supposed to be funny this movie was
written by John Patrick Shanley it's in
the same mood as his movie Joe versus
the volcano it was hilarious yes and
Dominic from videogame confessions as a
good British accent bully Baker
some of their arguments didn't even make
sense like one of my favorite seems that
sailor you can't see all of his won
they're reviewing the lost world now why
couldn't that little creature have been
more friendly these are wild beasts I
know they exist from a time long
millions of years before man they not
friendly but no I have three children
Roger and I have not that I've decided I
will not buy them a dinosaur as a pet
Ebert holds this expression for eight
seconds eight seconds I counted they
just look at each other in silence until
Ebert finally moves on to the next movie
how do you respond to that say I never
got shipment to drive my car never hired
an orangutan to cook my food Christ
pie was frozen today there you go I knew
that coming here in 1998 things started
to take a turn for the worst Cisco was
checked into the hospital for treatment
of a brain tumor but did that stop the
guy from reviewing films fuck no he
actually did the reviews from his
hospital bed with a picture posted like
he was right there
Roger I think that the writer was a
little creepy but it still showed he had
balls but he'll there's a way to get
something done you just take that way to
get it done isn't that right Monty oh
yes good just do your best and you will
succeed yeah that guy has balls dummy
yes by the way what are you doing in the
hospital
oh I am officially a pussy well I don't
know that facially makes us
Cisco eventually returned back to work
but you could already see his health
starting to deteriorate Armageddon is
appropriately named because while you're
seeing it you will feel as though you've
been in combat
he seems slower and more tired you
barely even argue with you for as much
as just smile cut so quickly that's that
there's no a stretch of action I gave
the rock thumbs up but this build and
when it stops for drama like when
they're all saying goodbye to each other
but as always he kept to it like the
true professional day was but as the
shows went on Siskel just seemed to get
slower and slower until he checked
himself back into the hospital for
further treatment of the brain tumor and
Sayle it was the last time he'd ever
check himself in Gene Siskel died from
complications at the surgery in 1999
leaving a great legacy behind him Eber
did an entire show dedicated to his
friend and associate even to this day
it's still pretty hard not to get teary
eyed while watching him whenever he
interviewed someone for his newspaper or
for television Gene Siskel always like
to end with the same final question what
do you know for sure okay gene what do I
know for sure about you well you were
one of the smartest funniest quickest
men I've ever known and one of the best
reporters and I know for sure that
seeing a truly great movie made you so
happy that you tell me a week later your
spirits were still high people always
asked if we really hated each other one
thing I know for sure is that we didn't
but as Ebert showed us the show must go
on
so the continuation began of our
placement was needed to fill the seat
and several guest critics were tried out
some of them were good some of them were
bad they even got Harry Knowles in there
somehow how the fuck did that happen
should we be helping he-man and Masters
of the Universe but I digress they
finally found a replacement Richard
Roeper how much younger and more
energetic critic compared to Roger Ebert
but sadly not quite as up to par with
Gene Siskel Roper simply seemed too
young to be talking on the same level as
Ebert about a lot of these films for
example Ebert favorite movie assistant
Kate Romer is his first feeling stay off
nothing wrong with that I like the movie
also but it does certainly show the
difference between the two all right
come on I'm being punked right this
knowledge do your real review even
though it's obvious Roper really enjoys
and admires movies sisq Eber
practically breathed movies from what
they wrote to what they talked about
everything was moving rumor was a
columnist before he became a critic and
because of this he's sort of fell into
the same trap than most critics on TV do
trying to slip in the one wires that leg
thing that napkins good in a bad breath
but Hector knows what's right for the
kids I swear it seems like English is a
second language former the obvious joke
is half past dead would be a documentary
about Steven Seagal's career but now to
his credit he seems like a nice enough
guy these columns are funny he has great
respect for Ebert and I really liked how
he always promoted lesser-known actors
from the film TV Beauty but sadly
disaster struck again Ebert was
diagnosed with thyroid cancer and
underwent radiation treatments on his
salivary glands an emergency operation
resulted in losing his voice because of
this Eber has to leave the show to roper
and sadly would never return
the show now started roper and a series
of guest critics but after not being
able to agree with the new direction the
producers wanted to take it
Hooper left as well eight years ago
Disney and America's most beloved and
respected film critic Roger Ebert gave
me the opportunity to take the seat in
the balcony once occupied by the great
Gene Siskel my gratitude will never
cease I want to thank everyone who tuned
in and shared their passion for movies
it's been my privilege and now appear
that the television legacy of Siskel
Ebert Andrew
was officially gone and it was instead
replaced by these two douche bags and
lions and been making monkey which I
hate them already the show tried to
incorporate a lot more interviews
opening nights and a bunch of our
gimmicks it just didn't seem like the
original show because of this the show
did poorly and has since then been
replaced again by two more critics
Michael Phillips and ale Scott they're a
little better but it's still not the
same that wonderful chemistry and
creative energy that only Cisco Niebuhr
had would never be recaptured but then
again maybe it shouldn't be that's
probably what made them so great to
begin with they both shared an
understanding and companionship that no
other person could duplicate I think
that's what makes it all the more
special and all the more lasting plus
both Richard Roeper and Roger Ebert are
still writing and despite this operation
Ebert says he feels fine actually I
think he looks kind of cool I mean he
has a permanent smile on his face that's
actually kind of Awesome in fact I tried
having a permanent smile once but only
lasted two days in fact every time I
smile now it hurts like a bastard Jesus
horn if I thought you got to meet Roger
Ebert at a book signing near Chicago
your autograph want my favorite books of
his your movie sucks in fact I have a
book right here look at a pissed-off
face I can only hope to see so many bad
movies I get that pissed off so let's
see exactly what he wrote your movie
sucks but you don't Roger Ebert ah you
hear that anyone who doesn't like me out
there
Roger Ebert one of the greatest critics
of all time says I don't suck only my
movies suck my movies suck ha what so if
you don't watch your share of Siskel and
Ebert wonderful reviews you can check
them out at Cisco near accom where they
literally have every episode they've
done all the way from 1986
that's unbelievable give a watch and see
why these two are considered the
greatest movie critics of all time I on
this couch agree
remember it so you don't have to
he certainly has strong